hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what's making the
headlines with the observer's chief
leader writer sonia soder and the chief
executive of conservative home mark
wallace welcome to both of you so let's
start off with a full look at the
newspapers then the metro leads with the
cabinet office minister steve barclay's
refusal to apologize for what a
parliamentary report uh has found were
serious government failings in the early
days of the pandemic
the ft carries warnings from the
international monetary fund that the
uk's post-pandemic economic recovery
will be slower than that of any other g7
country
the daily mail reports that the
government is planning to scrap social
distancing rules at doctor's surgeries
to allow gps to see more patients face
to face
from page of the eye the shipping
company musk is diverting its larger
vessels away from uk ports because of a
backlog of cargo which is waiting to be
processed
daily mirror leads with boris johnson on
holiday with a picture of the prime
minister painting
that is also the front page of the star
the telegraph meanwhile understands the
european commission will attempt to
resolve the post-brexit dispute over
northern ireland by setting out new
proposals
and that's also the lead for the
guardian with the headline eu to offer
olive branch on northern ireland goods
while the yorkshire post speaks to
baroness mcintosh of pickering who says
the energy price cap should also include
alternative fuels to make them more
affordable in rural communities like
hers in north yorkshire
so we're joined by mark wallace and
sonia soda lots of different stories all
many of them sort of interconnected but
let's start with that report that
parliamentary report by the the two
committees uh no apology as we heard on
the morning airwaves today um what does
the government do about this sonia
well i mean this has been a big story
that's been taking on all day the report
from the joint committees um in
parliament the health and the technology
and science select committee and there
weren't really many surprises in this
report but it was very significant and
weighty so it sort of brought together
findings from lots of expert witnesses
about government failings um in dealing
with the pandemic and i think lots of it
won't come as news to people who
followed this closely
uh but the significance was really in it
being drawn altogether and then you know
two very influential cross-party
committees with actually both um both
led by mps who served as as very senior
conservative members of the cabinet
inducing this very damning report
and i think this sort of i think the
lack of apology from the government it's
quite hard to understand in some ways
because it's really obvious that the
government made some very serious
mistakes with the way it dealt with in
the pandemic um some of those mistakes
it's got in common with other countries
and i think the public have got a lot of
time for the idea this was an
unprecedented crisis and
not everything was going to be got right
some mistakes i think you can say well
actually the government just repeatedly
made the same mistakes in quite an
unforgivable way but it just seems
extraordinary to me i think this is one
of the things that members of the public
don't really like about politicians when
it's obvious you've got things wrong you
do kind of need to say you're sorry and
kind of take some responsibility for
that and that has been really missing
from ministers response today now
there's all sorts of political reasons
why you may not be want to be caught
kind of in an interview with the today
programme or with another program saying
you know court saying that you're sorry
but i just i just don't think that that
makes sense to the public given the
findings so i think it's one of those
things that just comes across as very
cynical media management by a government
when actually it's blatantly obvious the
government got some quite serious stuff
wrong there's stuff actually that the
government got wrong you know which was
the prime minister
not really learning from mistakes
earlier in the pandemic it's not a
surprise that a very weighty report came
out and said that so why not just accept
some responsibility and say you're sorry
yeah i mean it's interesting isn't it i
mean we heard them clearly all the way
through i mean first of all we all
followed it closely because we all lived
it uh but but secondly the government
had that excuse of we were following the
science right from the get-go as if they
were waiting to have that you know in
their back pocket ready for days exactly
like today it does not excuse the fact
that they were simply asleep at the
wheel with with almost what looked like
zero planning in january february and
march which led probably to that delayed
lockdown and excess deaths as we heard
today mark are there any excuses
well there may be reasons but they ought
not to be excuses but the fact is one of
the reasons why a report like this
happens and the first of what i expect
will be several reports inquiries of
various different sorts is to find out
the reasons firstly the detail of what
went wrong when and why secondly what
went right when and why and thirdly the
you know the reasons and therefore how
you can try and resolve some of those
things i don't think it's the case that
when they were talking in the early
months of the the crisis about following
the scientific advice they were using
that as an excuse frankly this report
finds in the early months that they did
follow the scientific advice which i
think
as i recall in that time there was
pretty general outcry for for them to do
so
part of the issue what picks out quite
rightly is that as well as ministerial
and political mistakes there were also
mistakes in what advice was how advice
was formed what advice was given and
what advice was listened to rather than
challenged and that's that i think is
also really important frankly from this
report it's really crucial to see
the question of how even
the brightest minds even in the nation
even the experts the professional
agencies the political advisors the
politicians themselves can fall victim
to
fundamental fallacies issues like group
think and so on which are hugely hugely
costly and that that is also i think
probably one of the things we focus on
from this report how do we avoid that
happening again in you know go off a bit
another pandemic but you know military
crisis or energy policy or anything else
but even now we are accepting for her
death rate and far her caseload than our
european neighbours for example 181
people dead in the last 24-hour period
38
250 cases um and this call in the
guardian and elsewhere you know all day
today for this full public inquiry to be
heard earlier we still don't have a
the appointed judge of course and many
suggesting uh maybe not the families but
many suggesting this this should be a
lessons learned inquiry and not a
finger-pointing exercise sonia
well i think that's the whole point of
running an inquiry like this it really
is to learn the lessons and do do things
differently going forward
and actually i think that's why
the the quicker you have inquiries like
these the better i think there is there
are some really important learnings that
come out of the set committee report but
there's nothing quite like an
independent inquiry um that is led by a
judge i mean i think the danger is with
this is that if it takes a really really
long time to set up
um that you know there will be long term
lessons but actually we're still in the
middle of this pandemic there is still
lessons that could be learned that
actually could be applied in like one
month two months so i do understand the
cause for this to be brought forward and
i think it is really important that it
is particularly i think the families um
and and we've seen lots of of the
families who've who've been bereaved out
talking on the airwaves today i think
some of them have been quite upset about
this report i understand why but because
it's focused on the positives as well as
the negative so it's focused on the
nature of the vaccine program and you
know personally i think it is important
to acknowledge what's gone well as well
as what's gone badly but i can see why
why if you've lost a relative in the
early stages of this pandemic or even
later on and it was down to government
failings why that might not feel like it
strikes quite the correct home but but i
think this is another reason why
families are pushing for this inquiry to
be brought forward and i just i don't
really see the reason why it might it
needs to wait until uh next spring we're
not in kind of urgent urgent crisis mode
right now as we speak and it just feels
like why put off learning the lessons um
because we just never know what's around
the corner and when we might need to
apply these lessons the government
always said as well all the way through
that any action they brought had to be
balanced with the economic impact which
takes us to the financial times and the
uk recovery will lag behind other
advanced nations they suggest uh the
crisis is set to bring more
longer-lasting damage to the uk than any
other country in the g7 and there's
always been this question about lockdown
brings economic hardship versus those
who believe that late lockdown
exacerbated the economic impact but uh
but either way um the uk not coming out
of this very easily by the look at this
article
yeah i mean ultimately the reason for
economic damage through through all of
this in its most fundamental level is
that there's been a global plague but
the question is you know reflecting on
just what sonia was rightly saying about
the things an inquiry
for example should look into is how do
you weigh these different um
elements different aspects because if
you um you know when when the virus
running completely rampant obviously
does huge economic damage um people's
natural even voluntary reactions to a
situation like that when people were
locking down before lockdown um on a
voluntary basis that does economic
damage
lockdowns and policies necessary to
to reduce or even stop the virus also do
economic damage the question is
now i i think there's always a danger
for politicians in being too wedded to
things like imf forecasts you see the
treasury today understandably trumpeting
the fact that the imf also finds that
the uk is going to be the fastest
growing of the g7 this year um you know
they cling on to the they cling on to
the good bit but then the same point
here if you give that credibility then
the same report also points to this
scarring over the longer term so
i i hosted an event last week at the
tory conference look with some of the
members of the science and technology
committee professional
professor of behavioral psychology at
the lse talking about exactly this
question how do you get the right
evidence the right advice how do you
weigh it all up and that i'm afraid to
say including some of our colleagues in
the media um are it is something that's
continuing to prove extremely
challenging and how you see your way
through and out of this crisis well i
mean in many respects the crisis
continues in its own vein doesn't it um
well not that crisis but the multiple
crises facing the government let's just
show the ft once again
and this is the world's largest shipping
company which is now diverting uh its
containers away from britain's biggest
port uh which is suffering one of the
world's worst backlogs of containers
being offloaded from ships because of a
shortage of truck drivers uh it's making
a number of the newspapers too got it on
the front page of the daily telegraph as
well so we will talk about that no doubt
more a little bit later on ships unable
to dock and unload goods for christmas
all part of the h2e drivers there's this
sort of vacancies issue uh plenty more
still to come including the issue of
brexit and its impact on northern
ireland back on the agenda we'll discuss
that next
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now mark wallace
and sonia soda welcome back to both of
you uh well two newspapers leading once
again on brexit and northern ireland um
is it the end of sausage wars as we know
it mark do you think
well it certainly seems to be getting
there more importantly and
more remarkably what we're seeing with
some of these reports for example the
telegraph's report that the eu is set to
offer um
some kind of new
deal over northern ireland is what this
is creeping closer to is do you remember
the term dare i say max fact maximum
facilitation something that was
described by the eu as negotiators a
couple of years ago as being magical
thinking impossible the idea that you
couldn't use uh new initiatives in order
to produce or eliminate checks on their
on on goods going from the uk into
northern ireland or somehow it would
make the single market collapse um and
now the eu in response to david frost's
request seems to be proposing just about
exactly that so the protocol intended to
ensure that the border between northern
ireland and the republic of ireland
stays open
along following along the lines of the
good friday agreement while at the same
time protecting the eu's single market
which we heard lord frost uh obviously
complain that they are having to police
a border right through their own nation
today but the need for checking on goods
crossing to northern ireland from the
rest of the uk has led to tensions and
the telegraph and the guardian
suggesting under the proposals from
brussels up to 50
of customs checks on goods would be
lifted and the figure is even higher for
controls on meat and plants which has
been the sticking point question is is
that far enough do you think sonia
it's hard to say because i think the uk
are playing really hard ball on it and
mark just referenced their david frost's
request i think that's quite a polite
way of putting it really i think what
it's really important
um i think i think what is important to
recognize is that the
sort of northern ireland protocol as it
stood it involved really significant
amounts of compromise on both sides it
was quite a hard struck compromise and
now we're in a position um where you
know the uk is saying we signed this up
so we signed up to this two years ago we
knew what it involved we knew it
involved uh czechs down the uh irish sea
uh except boris johnson just went out
and lied and told the public that it
didn't uh really strangely and now the
uk is basically saying this doesn't work
for us so they've it's sort of it's a
request is a very polite way of putting
it it's basically saying you've got to
play along with us and give us more or
this isn't going to work the eu are sort
of compromising further and we'll see
how far that goes okay sonia
oh okay i apologize well
us i do apologize we're running out of
time we'll see you very shortly uh sonia
soda and mark wallace thank you both
very much indeed
you